this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much for
expert to present on this topic because
what I'm passionate about this uh I
believe this will help you in your
careers
help you anywhere you go in your life
because presentation skills are skills
that you you can use anywhere in any
type of job that you get into also there
are basic communication skills a lot of
times and then just persuading somebody
to do something the things that I I'm
presenting here I've actually used uh in
several areas one of the area that I
actually use is for a personal friend
so I was trying to convince him to go to
Switzerland with me and he did not want
to go he didn't like traveling
internationally but uh but I know that
he did like some of this and so I went
to my presentation skills and I thought
how do I persuade him to go with me so I
put together an actual presentation
and I emailed it to him and I convinced
him actually after 10 years to go to
Switzerland with me so it's not only in
business but your personal life you
could use this also
so let's get into this
all right it's estimated that there are
30 million business presentations given
every single day
unfortunately what a lot of those
presentations all they do is to convince
the audience that they had wished they
never had attended the presentation
so I'm going to give you some tips on
how to avoid that how not to put your
audience to sleep but more importantly
to be able to convince them to take
action
Warren Buffett how many people have
heard of Warren Buffett raise your hands
he arguably he's one of the most
successful investors in history
now Warren Buffett had said that you can
improve your value by 50 by learning
communication skills or presentation
skills now Mr Buffett has a single
certificate on his wall in his office
and what it is I'll give you a hint it's
not his business certificate his
business degree it's from a class that
he took on presentation skills at the
beginning of his career Dell Carnegie
class
and while I couldn't get Mr buttock to
personally endorse my class or
presentation I'm sure that he would
Lodge your efforts to increase your
presentation or communication skills
MBA programs have long understood and
the value of presentation skills so
Chicago and Stanford and Harvard
Orton Columbia and Berkeley Haas and
many other communicate MBA programs have
included presentation skills in their
programs
now one of the unfortunate things is
that
people are deathly afraid of
presentations in fact there was a study
done by Harvard Business School where
they asked people would you rather give
a five minute presentation or for five
minutes have electric shocks put through
your wrist guess what most people show
they chose to have electric shocks put
through their wrist in another study
people were asked what is your biggest
fear presentation giving a speech was
number one death didn't even make the
list
so Jerry Seinfeld said if you're at a
funeral most people would rather be in
the coffin than giving the viewers
so I'm going to help you to again get
over some of the fears by giving you the
tools and techniques to become a more
confident person
you can have the greatest idea in the
world but if you cannot persuade enough
people it doesn't matter
science even math
the most logical of Endeavors is a
social activity what happens if somebody
has a a new Theory what do they do they
go and tell their colleague hey what do
you think about this and that is
published and it's peer review
and and it's just it's a social type of
activity we have to convince others that
our ideas have value and Merit and if we
can't
an idea may just fail
so
um this is for the online presentation
so
um now as people feel free to enter into
the chat Windows some of the challenges
that you face but uh for the audience
that's here in the room what are some of
the challenges that you face when
preparing presentation content
just shut it up yeah the balance between
uh overwhelming my presentation or
underwinding my presentation sorry what
was that
the balance between to find the balance
between overriding my presentation
slides and underwording them
over okay
over wording and underwording yes okay
what's another one what's another
challenge that you face when preparing a
presentation
yes the audience knowledge like putting
my presentation to the audience the
audience knowledge absolutely extremely
important I think there was another hand
up over here
time time yes okay how much that you
have one person said I would have
prepared a shorter presentation but I
didn't have enough time preparing a
short presentation often takes more time
than a longer one yes
what type of visual dates that you use
absolutely yes linking topics or science
okay yes the transitions between
different topics all the yeah very very
valid things
well I'm going to talk to you about
Aristotle and his ideas behind
persuasion
Aristotle was a philosopher that lived
2000 years ago and he had three he had
thoughts on the three most important
aspects of what makes a persuasive
argument
and science is actually validated a lot
of those ideas since that time and the
three ones that he really believed were
important were in Greek ethos pathos and
logos or credibility emotion and logic
and he believed that you had to have
three components of a persuasive
argument and you needed to have all
three so I'm going to go and talk about
each one of those components and how
they fit into a persuasive argument now
I have to tell you my background is in
Computing science and I really thought
that this all this is all that matted
logic your data as long as you had
enough data and you had a logical
argument you could convince anybody of
anything and it took me 20 over 20 years
to actually get myself off of that and
realize that that emotion is really
important and establishing credibility
is also really important
so to prepare a persuasive presentation
you need to be able to establish your
credibility I'm going to talk about
making it memorable with structure and
then the power of story
so let's talk about each one of us
first of all let's talk about
credibility establishing credibility
well for establishing credibility you
need to accept you need to provide your
credentials up front
give your audience a reason on why they
should believe you
and this is really important up front
because if you do have if you do
convince your audience that you are
believable and credible that makes the
rest of the presentation that much
easier now you could establish
credentials up front for yourself or
maybe it's your group or maybe your
company whatever it might be but
establishing credibility is really
important so giving your audience a
reason to listen to listen to you and
generally you want to spend the least
amount of time to get the job done if
you spend too much time you come off
egotistical oh look at me I'm so great
but you do want to establish credibility
so here's here's some ways that you can
do that and remember that results are
more important than experience I can say
yeah I have 30 years of experience but
more importantly the results if you can
if you can tell people what results that
you've gotten in the past
that's more important than experience
okay so here's an example of what I do
it takes me 30 seconds at the beginning
of my classes that I teach I teach
classes on presentation skills at
Western Digital and outside
I say my name is Justin strong I have 30
years of presentation experience I'm an
instructor and author of presentation
skills at Western Digital and my classes
typically get 4.9 out of 5 stars
30 seconds I'm done then I'm off to the
rest of my presentation
so I do have experience here but more
importantly results
people say oh wow other people have
really uh enjoyed your class and they've
gotten a lot out of it perfect okay so
um that's what I do
um so your credibility statement is
going to look a little bit different
than that however you do need to
establish your credibility hopefully at
the beginning of your presentation
and people will see you more credible if
somebody else refers to you as an
authority on the subject and it turns
out that that person doesn't necessarily
need to be an expert themselves so there
was a study done at a real estate office
where the receptionist would answer the
phone in one of two ways the first way
was I'll put you through to Mary she is
one of our real estate agents
and the second way was just slightly
different she said I'll put you through
to Mary she has 20 years of experience
selling homes
now the receptionist is hardly a expert
on real estate agents
however just that one small change
results in 20 more assistance and 15
more signed contracts
so if you could get somebody to
introduce you at the beginning of your
presentation and refer to you as an
expert in the subject and however you
want to establish your credibility that
will definitely help
okay I'm going to skip this one over
um let's go on to the next one which is
logic okay this is the one I think of
and and I still think of when I first
what data do I have what logical
arguments do I have well
uh one of the things that you want to do
is provide structure to your logic so
here's an example of a presentation
where it had a really good structure now
Steve Jobs is one of my heroes he is
what I feel is one of the best product
managers that have ever lived I'm a
product manager at Western Digital and I
kind of view him as one of the product
manager Heroes now his iPhone
introduction the first presentation when
they first revealed the iPhone was
considered one of the best business
presentations and here's some of the
reasons why
he had a structure in his presentation
and a structure kind of went like this
first he presented what is so he talked
about all of the phones that existed at
that time
there was a Blackberry I think a Nokia
there was a palm Trio and let's see that
was uh
motor Motorola right those are the
phones that existed at that time and he
said well you know they have some
problems with them they have a fixed
keyboard
they have a fixed keyboard they have a
screen that's relatively small and
they're not really very easy to use
and they have a stylus that you that is
difficult and you always lose it he says
but what if
you had a large screen that took up the
whole phone and you didn't have a fixed
keyboard you didn't have to worry about
a stylus that you could lose and
everything just worked together like
magic
so he said what is what's the current
situation what could be what if you had
this and then you introduced the
solution the iPhone
so very simple structure in his
presentation
but really
served as a way to describe his solution
to the audience
there's lots of different structures
that you can use but the point is here
is that when you have a logical argument
in data when you put it into a structure
it's easier for your audience to
remember in fact there was a Stanford
study that said people are 40 percent
more uh liable to remember data that's
structured rather than unstructured
okay so that is uh so the the structure
that he used is what is but what if and
here's my solution you can use this in a
lot of your presentation here's the
current situation the problem that we
face but what if we didn't have to deal
with those problems and then you have
your audience ready for for your
solution
now a lot of times what people do is
they'll put the solution up front and
that's certainly a valid way of
presenting
um but this is also very interesting and
good way because it sets your audience
up to Really Want Your solution because
they identify what the problems that
you're telling them and and you say Hey
what if you didn't have to deal with
those problems and they're like yes yes
how could you solve that and so then you
present Your solution
so here's an example structure you would
do your opening and let's say five
reasons why cloud storage will double
over the next three years
we're the global cloud storage leader
and then you're closing so that's a
another structure that you can use you
have your opening you've got five
reasons why your your particular
proposal is true
and then you're telling your audience
hey where are the cloud Global cloud
storage leaders and then you have your
closing which which may contain a call
to action to ask your audience hey check
out our website if you think that you'd
like to use our cloud storage
another thing you want to do is make
sure data relevant to your audience
there was a comment at the beginning on
hey how do I make sure that my audience
will understand what I'm talking about
so one of the things you want to do is
make your data relevant to your audience
well here's an example how to do that so
let's say that you work for a Solar
Company a company that produces solar
panels and you said our company saved
one billion of 1 billion kilowatt of
hours of electricity in the United
States
well if you're not part of the solar
industry you might say what's a kilowatt
hour and it's a billion very much is it
one percent of all
um you may not know if you're in the
industry but if you count it in
different terms you say our companies
say 15 minutes of all of the electricity
consumption in the United States now all
of a sudden even if your audience is not
in the electricity or solar power energy
industry they're going to understand
that
so you want to ensure that one you want
to understand who you're talking to now
if you're talking to
members of your audience who are in your
particular profession
then it's okay to use technical language
and this may be perfectly valid but if
you have members of your audience who
aren't in your particular industry or
you don't know
this would be a lot easier for your
audience to relate to so if you make
data relevant to your audience
they're going to be able to understand
it a lot easier and then relate to what
you're saying
foreign
so those are a couple of suggestions
when you have
logic and data to present to your
audience how you can make it easier for
your audience to consume it one put it
into a structure to make data relevant
to your audience now there's a lot of
other techniques and tools I teach a
two-day class in my company and we only
have less than an hour here so I'll give
you a couple of principles but there's
certainly a lot more that you can do but
those are two definitely
two principles that definitely will help
you to make your logical arguments more
relevant to your audience so number
three emotion the last one
so this is the one that I struggled with
a lot of times because one I thought
isn't this just manipulating your
audience right with the motion you know
when you see those ads for starving kids
in Africa and then you see them and
you're just yeah I thought people are
just manipulating your emotions
but I really have changed my thinking
then and realized that emotion is an
integral part of our decision making
process and in fact it's an integral
part of us taking action on on any uh on
any argument that we hear I'll talk
about the science behind that
so data leads us to conclusions but the
motion leads us to action
data leads us to conclusions but emotion
leads us to action
so Antonio damasio is a social scientist
and his specialty is decision making and
emotion
he's done a lot of research on that and
one of his most interesting experience
uh sorry one of his most interesting
experiments were with people whose
emotional part of their brain was not
functioning
these people could not feel any emotion
at all
now you would think that they would be
the best decision makers they would make
totally logical decisions they would be
like Spock
and not have to be impacted by their
emotions
well it turned out to be exact opposite
was the case
that those people whose emotional part
of their brain was damaged and they
couldn't feel any emotion at all
could not make any decisions at all they
couldn't decide what to wear in the
morning they couldn't decide what to eat
for breakfast
they couldn't decide what uh what shoes
to put on and when Antonio asked the
subjects in this experiment hey what's
going on how come you can't make any
decisions they said well we know what we
should do we just can't bring ourselves
to do it
so data leads us to conclusion but
emotion will lead us to take action
so that's data well what do we do with
it right do you want to make your
audience cry in every presentation that
you have or you know make them laugh or
whatever well
not really no but there is a way that
you can bring out emotions in your
audience uh that are perfectly valid and
and are not manipulative and one of the
best ways to do that is through
storytelling
storytelling will elicit emotions in in
people
in a non-manipulative way
and help them to take action we are born
storytellers and story listeners in fact
we used to use stories to transmit Vital
Information that we needed to survive
we used to transmit information people
would sit around the fire at night and
sit and tell each other how they
survived during a drought
or what happened when the herds went
away and they had to find new places to
live and that storytelling is how we
transmitted Vital Information that we
needed
so we are wired for storytelling so how
do we use that in a business environment
well I didn't believe in the power of
Storytelling until one day
uh I had to give a presentation I had
been on a business trip to the UK and
I've been there for a month
and we were working with the largest
cellular phone provider in in Europe
and we were working on a project with
them
and I was there for a month and helping
them with the implementation and the
project and I came back I came back on a
Friday
I was back in the office on a Friday and
Friday morning my boss came to me and
said the executives want you to present
what your findings were they want you to
talk about what results that you got
I was a little bit nervous because while
we I had some achievements we didn't
really have a lot of data to present
and I had presented to the executives
before I left and I put business case
after business case together showing
what return on investment that we would
get
however before I went I knew that our
project was at risk was at risk of being
defunded
so I was really nervous I didn't really
have any new data to present and I
really believed that you should really
make data based decisions
and I really didn't have a lot of new
data to present but I did have some
stories to present so
they wanted I had to do it I couldn't
refuse and so I went into the
presentation with all the executives and
I told stories about how the customer
was happy about what we were doing about
how they had some successes in some of
the areas
and I finished the presentation and
I thought well okay I guess you know
whatever will happen will happen Monday
morning I came in my bus goes Justin's
congratulations and I go what yeah the
executives want to fully fund your
product
but why
I didn't present any new data all my
business cases they were lukewarm
responses to them
and yet I told stories and now all of a
sudden they want to fully fund them
and uh honestly it took me years after
that to really comprehend
the power of story and it wasn't until I
had done research
on the power of story and then thought
back to that experience and I had my aha
moment oh
stories really do have power to lead
people to take action
I had the data now don't get me wrong
data is extremely important you need
that
but you also need stories to help bring
it to life and to lead your audience to
take action
Richard Branson how many people have
heard of him
he is the CEO of Virgin Enterprises
um he said regardless of the medium
there is nothing more effective and
affecting than storytelling every year
he brings his top Executives to his
private island Necker Island and they
gather around a virtual fire and they
tell stories about their business and
how their successes and failures and it
really believes in that power
Jerome Bruner uses an educational
researcher he says when you have data
that's couched in a story people are 22
times more likely to remember it
I'll teach you more times likely to
remember data that's been a story than
not
well in the analysis of TED Talks 500
TED Talks someone did an analysis of 500
TED Talks actually it was
um Carmine gallo and he's a very famous
speaker and he wrote a book called The
the
Storyteller Secret
and he did an analysis of 500 TED Talks
and
um
he looked at the percentage of those
talks that were emotion story data and
credibility so what percentage of it was
evolved with involved with storytelling
or emotion data and credibility
well I'm just going to go through well
65 was data motion and storytelling oh
before I go any further how many people
have not heard of TED Talks okay I just
want to make sure I I know it's but some
audience that I talked to uh some people
haven't heard of it 25 was data and 10
was credibility TED Talks are considered
I think in a lot of people's career the
Pinnacle of presentations if you get
invited to do a TED Talk you're
considered one of the best storytellers
or presenters in the world and so the
world's best presenters 65 of their
presentations are storytelling or
emotion
let me give you another example I work
for a company called Western Digital we
make hard drives we own the company
called SanDisk which makes flash memory
flash memory cards uh we're totally data
driven
now if I went to let's say I was doing a
customer presentation and I said 65 of
consumers lost data from a computer or
mobile device in 2019.
now that's data it leads you to
conclusions wow that's terrible yeah
but what if I added a story to that
I said my hard drive failed last year
and I lost all the photos from the first
three years of my children's life
just imagine how upset my wife was
my wife laughs because this has some
truth
but now you tell a story and now people
are like oh
I don't want that to happen I need to
find a solution what what solution do
you have so data leads you to
conclusions
about a story and this is a very short
story
but would lead you to take action
because now you've seen how it applies
to you
so data these conclusions of
Storytelling or emotion leads you to
action
can you tell an effective story in two
sentences
again another kind of personal story my
wife came to me and said hey we should
get an Apple TV
and in the next sentence wait what is an
Apple TV anyway
That's The Power of bread
she was so enamored with Apple products
I had to have one even though she had no
idea what it did
so yes you can count an effective story
in just a couple of sentences you don't
have to have long stories in fact you
don't have to have a story that's
really um exciting or overwhelming to
your audience but if it's sincere and
it's relevant to the topic that you're
talking about
it can be effective and that's one of
the things you have to remember when you
choose a story it has to be related to
the topic that you're talking about some
stories are great
but maybe great for another presentation
and not this one
okay so in summary
we have three aspects to a persuasive
presentation and to have a really
persuasive one you want to have all
three
you want to have of course your data and
your logic
do you want to establish your
credibility up front
and then ideally have some type of a
story uh in your presentation
uh start how are we doing for time
it's yeah if you can finish one minute
yeah one minute yeah
um Okay so
one of the things that I do also and
this is I'm going to use one minute to
talk about this is that I use a Content
development worksheet and I'll send this
to you so that you can look at this I
use what I call content development
worksheet for every presentation that I
do I did it for my friend's presentation
I did it when I had to do a eulogy last
year for my best friend every
presentation so what is it what does it
contain you first of all you want to
know who your audience is and what do
they care about
your outcomes what you want your
audience to know as a result of your
presentation and what you want them to
do
then there's your supporting material so
this is you know your logic uses the
need of your presentation
your topics and I have a reminder here
you use emotion logic and credibility so
this is you and you want to have a
structure in this area this is where you
have your structure and then finally
you're opening and this may sound
character intuitive but I do my opening
after I do all this material
capture your attention of your audience
establish your credentials and then your
closing summarize and have a call to
action what is it that you want your
audience to do as a result of your
presentation
don't forget to leave this out
almost always you should have some type
of thing that you want your audience to
do with and it may just be go to my
website read my paper take a look at
this data whatever it is but you should
have something otherwise what's the
point of the presentation you want your
audience usually to do something
okay well thank you so much for
listening
um this is part of the content
development worksheet that will let you
there so here's your assignment my call
to action for your next presentation one
add a story
to your next presentation you might find
this difficult but I found that if I
really look there's a story in almost
every presentation even if it's very
very technical
establish your credibility at the
beginning of your presentation and
number three use the content development
worksheet and again we'll send it out to
you so that you have a copy of that all
right thank you very much for listening
thank you so much Justin
all right so for people on the line also
in the room I did a terrible job in
establishing Justin's credibility by
introducing him but that was not
accident okay it's intentional I'm going
to do the assignment I'm going to tell
your story
all right okay that's my assignment to
tell a story
I was struggling with persuading my
audience I do too much data that's the
feedback from many many people including
maybe Kylie and many many people so I
thought what I'm going to do okay so
Adida emba last two years while
finishing while doing my full-time job
so I graduated in May after that I felt
they told me how to handle the data all
the analytics I took the digital
transformation this is not didn't really
help me to be more effective in
persuading people
then what I did was this summer I joined
a cloud called Career boot camp where I
made adjusting and he thought about this
the seminar
and as he mentioned
yeah
so the persuasive
take action
I was persuaded so I took action I
emailed him and I thought I could invite
him to talk to all of you on Zoom he's
from California okay working in Vice and
digital
and how sincere he is he's here in
person
all right so hopefully you have a
wonderful uh learning and now time for
your present uh for your questions okay
anyone yeah before I tell you more story
because how loud to share okay
wow come to Toastmaster maybe I do a
plug there okay so yeah addition to the
unzoom opened everywhere yeah locally we
also how Toastmaster Club public
speaking so as students faculty and
other people from Colonel outside
Colonel we are very diverse age
profession yeah it's helped me to be
comfortable here oh yeah Kelly
uh just a I guess a quick question out
of curiosity right so I I feel like
I'm sort of so tied to like using
PowerPoint and kind of sort of these
standard ways of putting together
PowerPoint presentations you know as
someone that specializes in this do you
have any recommendations of of other
ways of putting together a presentation
that's maybe not so PowerPoint Reliant
how are you um yeah instead of
PowerPoint yeah uh well
it really depends on the presentation so
a lot of presentations but if you listen
to Ted Talks some of the talks don't
have any slides at all and that's
perfectly valid slides though if you do
have them should support you as the
presenter you are the star of the show
not your slides the slides should be
should be supporting you and should be
showing some information but you are the
person that they have come to listen to
otherwise they can just take your slides
and just watch them at home
so make sure that if you do have slides
that they are are supporting you and not
the focus of the presentation you should
always be the focus of the presentation
so you can have a perfectly valid
presentation without any slides now as
far as are there other options other
than slides where you can have a
presentation well sure one would be to
have some type of an object
are objects that you bring up and you
can have a combination of slides and
objects that you have in your
presentation
I've used different techniques within
PowerPoint and zoom there's actually one
star did you attend the presentation on
how to present like a broadcaster yeah
okay so what I did is is that there is
capability within Zoom
to take your PowerPoint presentation and
put it as a background so what I did is
I created a virtual broadcasting studio
in PowerPoint I put a suit on I got
myself situated and looked like I was
actually behind a desk in a presentation
in a broadcast studio and I gave my
presentation that way so if you look
into into PowerPoint and zoom look into
a feature it's a beta feature I think in
zoom on using PowerPoint as a background
and so you can use PowerPoint and so you
kind of are almost immersed in the
presentation itself
um also within I don't know if you use
teams at all here or yeah so in teams
you can present uh there's different
presenter views where you actually bring
you yourself into the middle of the
presentation uh or on the side and your
slides are right beside you and I like
to do that because it instead of just
being a little boxed onto the site you
actually are in your presentation right
next to your slides so that's another
way that you can bring yourself and and
bring yourself front and center rather
than
present I call it presenting outside of
the box right and and you're actually
more of a part of the presentation so I
don't know if I fully answered your
question but there's a couple of things
there's a few things that you can do yes
yeah thank you very much for that
presentation which I find timely because
I was just contemplating presentation
that I have to give okay yeah I
appreciate the the tips that you're
providing but my I feel like my
questions are almost for the group
because I'm trying to interpret
a couple of things and wondering how
they would be maybe star is really a
good person to help with this like what
does it call to action in our science
topic so so you're gonna you know you
say you're a grad student a postdoc
you're giving your research I'm like
like what would be appropriate to regard
as being in the call to action that's
one thing and even like let our story
how do we interpret the word story and
the kind of work that we actually do now
I'm not saying that's that harder
question but it's still a lot of
examples of what kind of would count or
be powerful in that and you know our
context I don't know if you're the right
person to answer well let me answer one
of your questions that you've had and
this is what I get from a lot of people
within who are in engineering and
finance and they say I don't there's no
stories there's just numbers
I'm saying you can always find a story
so one example is let's say that you're
presenting your the end of the quarter
numbers and it's just okay we made 40
million dollars and we achieved and we
had a 10 million dollars profit
okay well yeah those are just numbers
and and so I have Finance people that
tell me how do I put a story if there's
no story behind it well there always is
so here's an example
you say today and uh I actually started
last week I went to the CFO and and I I
told them hey
guess what I've got an envelope sitting
on this desk
and in it is our as our end of the
quarter numbers guess what they were and
he goes
I think it was about 35 million
a little bit higher
um 38 million not a higher
it's more than 38. yeah
um
about 39. it was 40 million now very
simple story
right and you might think well it
probably doesn't have a lot of meaning
but when you couch a number in a story
people are more likely to remember that
number remember that statistic where
Jerome Bruner said you're 22 more times
likely to remember a number if it's
couched in a story well if I told the
story like that
and how more likely do you think that
people are to remember the 40 million
number that if I just said oh here's our
numbers we got 40 million dollars of
Revenue and we achieved 10 million
dollars in profit so very simple story
and again your stories don't have to be
complicated and overly dramatic they can
be a very simple story but if they're
sincere and if they're related to the
topic that you're talking about it could
be a struggle that you had in getting
some of the data it could be a funny
incident that happened but if you take
your data and wrap it in some type of a
story your audience is going to remember
it one and that's one of the things that
you want to do the sad truth is this is
that probably about 15 of your
presentation and and more will be
forgotten within 24 hours so that's one
of the challenges that you have as a
presenter how do you get your audience
to remember what you said for a longer
period of time and stories are
definitely one way to do that
how about the call to action yeah call
to action well I think I've I've turned
to the audience to say hey what are some
suggestions that people might have
because I think they would probably know
that better than me I'm not the subject
matter expert in what you're talking
about yes
so I put up a call to action as uh you
know you conclude a presentation but
then you talk about the
two other motion you would add that
impact of you know what's doing those
next steps would mean for yourself so
it's kind of your call to action to
yourself is that right is that
accountable that can be yes yes on the
audience you know yeah yeah I would
agree with the call to action is next
steps makes a lot of sense because it
can be a call to action for yourself but
also especially as students who
generally will have like a small part of
the project the call to action is to the
your field and saying like this is what
I've added and these would be the next
logical steps of the encouragement that
you hope that someone else will take on
the research and help develop your ideas
further yeah that makes sense yeah it
might be hey does anybody have any
suggestions on me yeah I can try to
understand it yeah Rebecca these are
things that we don't know what to do I'd
like to have people suggest you know
some things that we could maybe some
directions there could be several
different things I think or if you want
to people to go to your website a
website or
um to a paper or something to get more
information that could be it right if
you're interested this is where you go
for more information now that's one
thing I always do is that for more
information here's where you can go
one thing I can think of is uh why the
power of social media yeah you can see
it's rising I think it's a part of once
personally you want to take action and
through your own posting your own
blogging that can really get a lot of
people really see the impact on
themselves so it's more powerful than
you even send a real publication
proposal sometimes yeah yeah please
Justin in terms of credibility you talk
about storytelling and then in injecting
that in your presentation can add value
but in terms of credibility if it's a
story that you're sharing that you
directly yourself experience versus
maybe telling a story that you heard
about that somebody else is there a fine
line there is there a difference does it
matter in terms of credibility uh well
for incredible Oh Oh you mean whether
people will believe like story that
somebody else not so much believe but
just uh in terms of adding that value
that credibility to your to your to your
speed does it carry more weight if you
yourself
experience versus somebody else okay so
there's a couple different aspects of
that certainly a personal story is
usually of more interest to the audience
when you tell a story of something that
happened to you personally especially if
you're talking about something where you
want to convince your audience to do
something and you can tell a story about
how you have been impacted by it
yourself so I told the story about how I
was impacted by storytelling and and how
it impacted me now if I told a story
about somebody else I think that's
perfectly valid that is but I think
there's something a little bit different
and a little bit more impactful when you
tell a story about that's personal
and and what actually happened to you
so both are definitely very valid
sometimes you can't find this you don't
have a story yourself right a personal
story so you it's definitely very valid
to use and I think can be really really
impactful if you tell a story that um is
related to your presentation but
somebody else experienced it yeah
so for the people on the line if you
have questions you'd like to give you
one chance okay yeah the last question
say for the people on the line anyone
it's
just a mute yourself
or send it through the chat okay yeah so
if not there's the amount of time so
Justin's going to meet graduate student
for lunch so graduate students are not
continue on the conversation all right
so let's give one more round of applause
to Joshua
thank you so what I really think uh
Justin the value of Hebron is from my
technical background computer science I
felt his worksheets also all the
techniques tools is very easy to follow
yeah so
three things to be persuasive I think we
can all replicate yeah just multiply all
right and if you see this as a value we
can definitely invite Justin back online
or in person in the future we're gonna
continue out okay with that please join
the lunch with Justin thanks
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu